the universe is incredibly big and seems
full of potential for life with billions
of habitable planets
if an advanced civilization had the
technology to travel between the stars
at just 0.1 percent of the speed of
light it could colonize our galaxy in
roughly 100 million years
which is not that long given the
billions of years the milky way has
existed so in principle any space faring
civilization should be able to spread
rapidly over huge sectors of the galaxy
and yet we see nothing hear nothing
the universe seems empty devoid of
others
this is the fermi paradox which we've
discussed in more detail in other videos
confronted with the seemingly empty
universe humanity faces a dilemma
we desperately want to know if we are
alone in the milky way we want to call
out and reveal ourselves to anyone
watching but that could be the last
thing we ever do
because maybe the universe is not empty
maybe it's full of civilizations but
they are hiding from each other
maybe the civilizations that attracted
attention in the past were wiped away by
invisible arrows
this is the dark forest solution to the
fermi paradox
[Music]
the way of life
the hunter awakes in his hiding place
and carefully listens for suspicious
noises from the thick undergrowth before
he gets up
another night has passed without
incident
the forest is dark and full of fog
he considers calling out to others to
end his loneliness
but stops himself at the last moment
what if they are like him
all living things seek to survive secure
resources and multiply
their greatest obstacle are other living
things that share the same objective
competition between species favored the
survival of beings with advantageous
traits
our ancestors were inventive competitive
expansionist and greedy for resources
which led them to winning the
competition for our planet
today most other animals are so utterly
at our mercy that we wipe out about a
dozen species a day just as an
unintentional byproduct of how we like
to run things
but humans are more than individuals
from us cultures emerge that also
compete with each other
competitive and expansionary cultures
spread faster and further and merge with
subdue or destroy others
if we look at our history it becomes
clear we are dangerous
not just to others but also to ourselves
our human nature has driven us to take
over every corner of our planet and soon
we will look to the stars both to expand
our domain and ensure access to ever
more resources
and then we might stumble upon others
trying to do the same thing
it's likely that the competition of life
also takes place on far away planets so
it's logical to assume that an alien
civilization that came to dominate their
planet would be in some regards similar
to us
but if they're similar to us
they too
may be dangerous
the implication
as the hunter sneaks through the dark
forest all alone he knows that there
might be others like him
he can't know their intentions if they
are aggressive or not
the hunter knows he would kill to ensure
his own survival so he has to assume
that they would too
and it might be that if he stumbles upon
another hunter the one that shoots first
survives
none of this means that conflict is
unavoidable so far the progress of the
modern world seems to have made us more
peaceful not more violent
maybe this is true for other
civilizations too that eventually
progress means less conflict not more
different alien civilizations also
should vary from the mild and peaceful
to the malevolent and
militaristic
the existential problem we're facing is
that when we meet others between the
stars we have no way of telling who is
peaceful or aggressive and what their
true intentions are
similarly they might not understand or
trust our intentions even if we tell
them that we are peaceful
on top of that if we did discover
another civilization and they discovered
us the light years between us would mean
years of communication delay
both sides would be in a state of
uncertainty wondering if the wisest move
is to just attack because there's
another serious issue technological
explosions and the first strike
advantage
we don't know where the limits of
technology are but we do know how much
technological progress matters in war
a few hundred or thousand years can turn
conflict with uncertain results into a
one-sided massacre
caesar's legions would stand no chance
against napoleon's army with their
cannons and muskets
which would be eradicated by artillery
from the first world war
which would not stand a chance against
today's drones and guided missiles
so the power level of different
civilizations may vary massively and
even if not between the time it takes us
to detect another civilization and us
saying hi we might already be hopelessly
behind on the tech tree
which is bad enough but the nature of
interstellar conflict makes this worse
if your opponent is light years away
sending an invasion fleet takes so long
that by the time it arrives it might be
hopelessly obsolete
so war between civilizations might be
just about eliminating the other to
remove an existential threat to yourself
someone else who might be so scared of
you that they attack the first chance
they get
in this environment the only way to
guarantee a win is to strike with such
force and speed that the target has no
chance of survival or time to
counter-attack or escape to seek revenge
later
the stakes are the highest possible with
no room for error
if we assume that the majority of
civilizations live on planets that
leaves them pretty vulnerable all you
need to do is throw something massive at
a planet to make it uninhabitable
so the ultimate interplanetary
annihilation weapon is probably
something like a relativistic kill
vehicle a missile shot at a planet at a
significant fraction of the speed of
light
for example a missile the size of a
person going 95 the speed of light has
as much energy as all nuclear bombs on
earth
if you shot a few dozen at the
civilization you wanted to wipe out
success would be fairly certain even a
single hit would suffice
this is not that absurd of an idea
a civilization only slightly above us on
the kardashev scale would have enough
energy to send multiple strikes against
every planet it suspects of harboring
life
what makes these weapons so sinister is
how much they favor a first strike since
they would be so fast that it might be
impossible to protect yourself
effectively against them once they're
launched
conflict between civilizations may not
be lengthy affairs but rapid winner
takes all situations where the first one
to shoot wins
this makes any civilization an
existential threat to any other
and if every civilization is an
existential threat to every other there
may be only two kinds of civilizations
out there quiet ones and
dead ones
so
what should we do
should we worry
it's unlikely that anybody has noticed
humanity yet
the radio signals we've transmitted in
the last 100 years travelled a
relatively tiny distance and have long
decayed into unreadable noise
at our technological stage if we don't
actively try to get noticed and if
nobody specifically looks at our pretty
unremarkable solar system will stay
hidden
but one day we will venture into space
in a serious way and need to consider
these kinds of questions again
we don't know if there are others or if
we are going through the forest alone
but we have no way of knowing for sure
for the time being it seems the best we
can do is to carefully listen
and even if we see others step into a
clearing and make themselves known we
should not reply right away but
carefully watch them from the
undergrowth
perhaps we are also thinking about this
all wrong by allowing our primitive
brain that evolved in the context of the
gruesome competition of life to conjure
fears of predatory aliens all around us
maybe the fact that we are looking at
the universe like this is a sign that we
are not grown up yet as a species
there could be a friendly welcoming
community of alien civilizations waiting
to hear from us when we are ready
as for now the good news is there is
actually little we need to do
we just need to be thoughtful about the
signals we send out into the galaxy we
need to watch the sky and learn more
about our galaxy our forest
because whatever the nature of our
forest is
full of dangers or friends or nobody at
all
only careful observation can tell
so
let's do that
at last the hunter reaches a clearing
and finds a comfortable position
slowly the sun melts the fog away
lost in thought
he admires the vegetation until suddenly
he is eye to eye with another hunter
frozen in terror just like himself
his mind is racing considering all the
different options
the hunter takes a deep breath
and makes a decision
maybe the only way out of the dark
forest
is to step into the clearing together
and with this hopeful picture we say
goodbye to the year 12021 of the human
era it was a wild year to say the least
still much more fun than twelve thousand
and twenty quadsquezak had its most
successful month ever and published a
book we tried a lot of new techniques
and really got into blender and cinema
4d hiding more and more 3d in our videos
we have so many ideas for next year and
big and ambitious plans that we can't
wait to share with you
and all of this was and is possible
because of your direct support
thank you so much kotzkuzak only works
because of you
so in tune with the end of the year
we've designed a few products that will
help you to visualize your place in the
universe our very shiny the night sky
poster shows you the little piece of
space we can see from earth with our own
eyes or travel further out with our
stellar zoom collection that depicts our
home in space from an increasing
distance
or dream with our space themed notebooks
scenic posters and pins
we design and produce every single
product with great care
getting something from our shop is the
best way to support kotskazaks
we hope you have a wonderful end of the
year and the 12022 is more fun and less
exciting than the last two years
thank you for watching
me
[Music]
you